have you ever cooked for any of those
celebrities on the show well the thing
is we did that we did a Christmas
special and girls Aloud came round my
house and we cooked them sandy dinner
yep I don't go Christmas dinner and
don't fare Arden told me about like you
massage the turkey don't you what it day
been you fat dyed it
I think she said to me Oh Alison you've
gotta wash your hands afterwards cuz it
spreads things half it was an old wives
tale and now we're at it do you know
what well the next five days coming out
bouquet and it's right is it true you've
got to wash your hands after you touch
yes it is
they're talking about it right now right
tomorrow fairy okay fine appletini right
it's not a puree
yes he'll make a little hole okay this
end of the pan yeah and sort of roast
off that to my puree now that starts to
give the chicken tikka masala sauce a
bit of colour more importantly a bit of
depth and a bit of richness yeah
so take off the tomato puree and that
sort of gets rid of that tart tanning
flavor associated with puree good now
that smells amazing
tin Tomatoes Allen pull your ring you're
better than that
tomatoes into the onions are but me here
we go now when did you first realize
you're gonna make a fortune in comedy
huh well I didn't know it people just
used to laugh at me I think there's a
void than the wall and it's funny I went
to a fortune teller in Camden and she
said you'll make said you're very funny
yeah uh-huh
cut hold the chair away sure about that
you paid money to a fortune teller to
television when she was spot on the show
at no no not badly funny but she knew
everything else about me when honestly
you'll make your money because I wanted
to be an actor you say yes I go no no no
I said I won't be good it said if I want
to act I want to be the new cracker but
I think she was a dirt yes because you
wanna you want the talking dog so you
she was right yeah I know need your
money and then she'd go I went back the
next day she'd gone yep and is it true
before yeah you started yeah you
starting what the warm-up on Jonathan
Ross yeah that's me yeah it was great I
just did it and I've met some amazing
people really really good give it a go
man who did it was a oh it ain't what
you don't care no I do care he's got a
lot of time on his hands so you should
we do the warm-up for you oh I get it
we're gonna blend assortment okay lucky
all that into the blender okay put the
pan back on top of the stove a little
teaspoon okay I'll grandma all back in
there and blend the sauce now back on
Blandon I feel like you've only met
sauce okay gives it really nice velvety
amazing texture given to me nicely fine
take your chicken okay
yeah put your chicken back into the pan
now we don't want to cook the chicken
just lightly sort of
saute it good nice excellent take out
the spoon good okay that's not good
you're good now once that's blended
off we go and look already it's amazing
nice and fine sauce now